اكبر عدوى فطريه في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده عدد الاصابات تتزايد بينها حالات
خطره فيما تم تسجيل حاله وفاه على الاقل
حتى الان وسط مخاوف من انتشار العدوى بشكل
واسع ما يحدث حاليا بامريكا هو تفشل للفطر
البرعمي وسط ترجيحات تقول ان مصنعا لصناعه
الورق بولايه ميشيغان هوره المرض الخطيره
الاولى المحققون اشتبهوا بان يكون الخشب
المتعفن هو الذي تسبب في اصابه اغلب موظف
المصنع وزائري بعد استنشاقهم ابواغ الفطر
ما دفع السلطات لاغلاق المكان ميزه هذا
المرض هي ان اعراض الاصابه به تستغرق
شهورا حتى تظهر وتتمثل في السعال والحمى
والم الصدر بسبب استهدافه الرئتين لكنه قد
ينتشر بعد ذلك الى مناطق اخرى مثل الجلد
والعظام والدماغ والمعروف انه لا ينتقل عن
طريق البشر